give me the box
oh kick throw oh my god oh
yeah you ain't gonna get away that easy
oh and right to the dimension that's
gotta make your classic straight you're
gonna barf in the suit
welcome back to new rock stars this is
the year of the shattering of the
multiverse and spiderman no way home has
done its part to crack that multiverse
open even wider we got the spider-man
family reunion we've all been waiting
for and each webhead got the sweet
resolution they've all been waiting for
but what is next for peter one now that
he's all alone again because he's very
much alone he's the most alone he's ever
been so alone so sad
it's the parker luck man it's the parker
luck this is inside marvel hour after
show for marvel sony's latest entry to
the marvel cinematic universe spider-man
no way home my name is mt and we're
going to talk about some of the biggest
revelations and burning questions left
over from this magnificent piece of
cinema it is cinema and discussing this
all with me is off screen producer
brandon brandon
what did you think about this dang movie
bro
mt this movie give this movie the oscar
give it the oscar from every universe
bring them in beautiful stuff it's it's
been a long time coming it was it was so
great to see it had fan service it had
great action it had everything we we
could want in an mcu film and my theater
had a blast uh they were rowdy for this
film they were rowdy bro if your theater
is not rowdy for this film uh you're not
a movie theater you're in a library that
that's a library you're in and go to the
actual movie theater because it's
impossible for this movie to not get you
hyped yes literally the end game
comparisons are legit for real drop it
drop in the clip of tom cruise seeing
tenet being like the movies are back
baby they're back
they're back for real this time the
movies are back but please be safe out
there whatever you do if you do the
movies please be safe mask up because
there's a lot of people there there's a
lot of people yeah there's no way that
you're going to go to an empty theater
yeah yeah but anyway before we dive into
our questions left over from the film
let's do a quick plot summer because a
lot happened here and also this goes
without saying
but huge spoiler alert if you have not
seen this film do not watch this video
if you have not seen this film because
this film is phenomenal so stop go watch
this come back okay cool but yeah we
begin right where spiderman far from
home left off with j jonah jameson using
the dailybugle.net to reveal the true
identity of spider-man thanks to you
know quentin beck's really petty nature
and leaked altered video he also accused
the spider-man of murdering back and
using the stark drones to cause
destruction around the world to several
national monuments because you know
spider-man just hates nationals it's
national monuments but then again ever
since you heard that you know the
washington monument was built by slaves
i i understand i understand he was
probably like you know what these are
all problems
but now that this info is out everyone
seems to be after peter and anyone who
knows him and the department of damage
control wants a word with peter on may
mj and ned but thankfully they know
their rights and lawyer up literally one
of my favorite moments in the film mj
and opmay we're not messing around and
like those are the kind of that's the
female energy i need in my life i need
to know your rights
and so yes peter lawyers up but it's not
just any lawyer it is matt murdock
himself as we sort of felt suspected and
hoped and boy that was a great scene
that was a fantastic rewarding scene one
of the many times i clapped during this
movie i'm not a theater clapper but like
oh man this movie got it out of me i'm
not a theater clapper at all and what a
great lawyer he is guys what a great
lawyer such a good i mean he caught that
brick you caught it i don't know how he
did it buddy it's the mystery who knows
uh maybe he's some type of daredevil
but all this press attention has hurt
peter mj and ned's dream plans of
getting into mit which is in
massachusetts where i live and peter
wants to fix things so he turns to the
sorcerer supreme but yay it's actually
vlog this time which makes a lot of
sense since doctor strange was gone for
five years and wong had to take over his
duties peter then turns to doctor
strange for help and dr strange tries to
do a little magic memory wipe so
everyone will forget peter parker
spider-man but then peter has second
thoughts during the incantation and then
tries to make sure some people close to
him remember who he is because it would
be kind of weird if everyone forgot
it'll be very lonely right it's a good
thing that doesn't happen at the end of
this movie or else you feel really alone
only the magic doesn't like that and
then goes haywire and starts making
holes in the universe yeah that can be a
problem so strange tries to contain this
haywire spell and he sends peter on his
way as peter tries to convince the mit
acceptance board to reconsider mj and
ned he's attacked on the bridge by none
other than otto octavius aka
boom oh boy
during the fight what a good fight it
was doc mechanical arms absorbed some of
peter's nanotech revealing to otto that
this isn't his peter no no no
with the nanotech bonded to the arms
peter's able to control the arms and
restrain doc
always pair your bluetooth people
it looks like peter's got the upper hand
but suddenly a pumpkin bomb signals the
arrival of norman osborne aka the green
goblin uh before peter can even react
he's portaled back to the sanctum where
otto is placed in a holding cell oh my
god i love that camera angle yeah that
being portable i was like what happened
yeah yeah it was like very confusing and
like even peter was like wait what who
i don't have to fight cool cool super
cool dr strange reveals that the broken
spell has caused people from other
universes that know who spider-man is to
get into our universe to get to
spider-man and strange has already
captured kurt connors aka the lizard
super easy not a problem for him uh and
now he needs peter to capture the others
so he can use his magic box to send them
back to the worlds that they belong in
uh he gives peter magical warping web
and sends him on his way with a net and
mt offering support via facetime you
said netted mt what
as much as i would love to be to team up
with spider-man and ned uh i can't i
don't i don't have the calcium
so after peter captures max dillon aka
electro and flint marco aka sandman
peter gets a tip from aunt may that
norman osborne is at feast uh and after
collecting him doctor strange is ready
to send everyone back to their
respective universes to meet their fates
uh but what are their fates you might
ask well it's death for some of them and
our boy peter doesn't like that and he
wants to cure them first but hey strange
is not having that because teenagers do
not know the big responsibility that
comes with being the sorcerer supreme
you gotta kill these guys or else
everyone's gonna die strange is strange
is all rocky four in this movie baby
he's all if he dies he dies
straight up he was like hey kid it's
just the job i do the [ __ ] every day i
don't want to hear it yeah yeah i killed
tons of people on the table it's not a
big deal
that's fate that's fate sorry folks it's
just wednesday my dude sorry
but yeah strange is not having any of
that and he and peter fight over the
magic box and by using the power of math
peter beats strange and then goes on a
mission of healing and i really love
that moment because i love anytime we
see peter's nerdness help him in battle
yeah that is straight up peter parker
like yeah and like showing off his
intelligence in like a really good way
which this movie did great the peters
were very smart in this movie and like
the fact that peter parker beat the
sorcerer's supreme well the former
sorcerer supreme yeah is a huge deal
because like no champ that's incredible
um then they use happy's secret stark
tech to start working on cures but after
fixing otto's inhibitor chip the green
goblin convinces the other baddies that
getting cured just ain't worth it being
bad is just too good and in the ensuing
battle aunt may is mortally wounded but
not before giving peter the most
important words he needed to hear that
with great power must also come great
responsibility kind of making it feel
like he's never heard that before which
is kind of a really special moment for
him for all spider-man fans but
meanwhile nedler's of his own magical
abilities and with the help of dr
strange's sling ring opens a portal to
try to find peter but only he doesn't
find his peter he finds two of the other
peters from peter's past and finally
everyone is reunited and the spider-man
unite to try and cure the villains it's
a showdown at the statue of liberty as
the spider-man learned to work as a team
and doctor strange breaks free of the
mirror dimension to see them working
together to change their fates and he's
like oh this is pretty good the kid's uh
he's actually doing it what an idea but
then a pumpkin bomb in the magic box
threatens to shatter the multiverse
completely and our peter knows what he
must do to fix it and that means letting
everyone in the world forget who he is
it works and everyone is sent home and
our peter is now truly on his own with
no aunt may no happy no ned no mj but he
has a new suit which is really great
like a brand new homemade suit that he
makes in his new apartment that is very
much that whole ending sequence felt
very spider-man ps4 yeah like it just it
was very very like oh man this is it
he's finally adult peter parker about to
do his thing and then of course after
the movie in the mid credits scene we
see eddie brock trying to piece it all
together with venom and a friendly
bartender who is just literally telling
the telling him the entirety of the
infidel just explaining the mcu it's
it's me at thanksgiving trying to
explain to my parents what i do for a
live i really i wish it was kevin feige
i i really wish i was there
that would have been hilarious
but just to start to get an
understanding of everything in the mcu
he gets sucked back into the venomverse
but not before leaving behind a little a
little lagoo actually like you on the
table that's a weird tip eddie so you're
typically behind but uh i mean you don't
have to report it on your taxes which is
the nicest oh yeah but hey uh i mean the
irs is already evil enough so we don't
need them having uh they got their own
and then of course after all that we got
a trailer for multiverse of madness
which is pretty crazy before we continue
our merch partners at the epic hero shop
have a new latest obsession shirt to
help you celebrate the biggest movie of
the year spider-man no way home and the
shirt is number 11 in the latest
obsession series and it's called strange
entanglement and like all the latest
obsession shirts there is a limited
supply and then the shirts will be
banished back to the vault so please
grab one right now before it disappears
yeah you'll check out the basically
don't forget you ever even saw this
shirt it will be wiped from your memory
you'll forget i even said this honestly
um we're working with doctor strange
it's a it's a really uh exclusive deal
so you can check out this lady's
obsession shirt along with our other
merch options from spiderman to hawkeye
to loki and more at
newrockstarsmerch.com and before we
continue we want to thank some of the
folks that are helping us bring this
show to you including stamps we recently
got a shipment of stan socks and we love
them they're very well made super soft
and have unique designs we got a little
glow up from the toes up founded in 2009
stance apparel represents a radical
reinvention of socks underwear and
active apparel with a sharp focus on
comfort quality and creativity stance
brings an atypical aesthetic alongside
some of pop culture's hottest
collaborators for the ultimate in style
and self-expression because everything
you wear should be a direct extension of
who you are and how you feel one of the
coolest parts of stance socks is the pop
culture collaborations they do they have
socks with designs from star wars the
office marvel and pixar right now and
i'm gonna grab some pixar socks so i can
have some cocoa on my toe toes uh i love
it
remember me
and it's cool to express yourself with
super comfortable super fun socks stance
believes that the perfect fit matters
more than fitting in that those who feel
good do good so go see for yourself
register for an account at stance.com
and get 15 off your first purchase use
promo code marvel at checkout to apply
enjoy the color and comfort of a life
less ordinary with stance we also want
to thank our friends at manscaped that's
right our friends at manscaped are here
to make sure that whatever your holiday
plans may be your chimney will be
looking clean make sure
make sure you're keeping things fresh
this winter with the leaders in mail
grooming and their brand new fourth
generation performance package join the
two million men worldwide using
manscaped and probably some of their
female partners as well by going to
manscape.com
marvel for 20 off plus free shipping the
manscape performance package is a great
gift idea for the guy in your life in
need of some grooming gear he can start
the new year off right and tight
manscape even threw in two that's right
two free gifts to their performance
package 4.0 the manscaped boxers and the
shed travel bag get comfy at home and on
the go this season get 20 off push free
shipping by going to manscape.com marvel
that's 20 off and free shipping by going
to manscape.com
marvel that's right folks if you didn't
get it the first time there's 20 off and
free shipping by going to manscape.com
marvel make your balls a priority this
winter choose manscaped your balls will
thank you yes your balls will grow
mouths each one will grow oh my god
don't put that visual into my head
jesus christ that's like a nightmare i
had
my balls being like what are you doing
to us
let us free
my crops you're destroying my crops my
beautiful cops i grew these hairs for
you and you shaved them off
what are you
some sort of prepubescent boy
i grew these hairs for you
i use so much testosterone to grow these
crops what am i doing with my life
but of course there's no better way to
start our discussion today than you know
that magical ending so our first topic
of the day is how did dr strange's final
spell even work because in the end peter
agreed to have everyone's memory wiped
of the existence of him in order to heal
the cracks in the multiverse but like is
everyone with the memory of peter parker
suddenly just like a little bit
lobotomized like what about mj's broken
black dahlia necklace that we still see
her wearing at the very end of the film
like does she not know where she got it
she's like oh i've always had this this
is totally fine yeah she seems like a
trendy like thrift store shopper so
maybe she's just like oh this is another
weird piece and like there might be a
part of her that is like oh i really
like this piece it means a lot to me i
want to wear it around i mean i was so
nervous that when peter walked into that
cafe and she gets in the donut she's
getting the donut to ned that they were
gonna like kiss and it was going to be
like me too they had like i was so
nervous about love in like a day or two
and i would be like no peter don't watch
i was very nervous for that look away
you don't need to see this
but yeah it was a pretty crazy spell huh
empty
this reminded me a lot of when i saw end
game uh and they did you know they do
the snap to blip everyone back and i was
like oh that was great and then i'm
leaving the theater and i'm like wait
how did how did like every little bit of
that work you know it's like i have so
many questions it's like well what about
this what about that yeah like are the
pictures of peter parker that were
around like all of a sudden gone like
harry potter style like that's i i find
it hard to believe that all like this
one spell just altered all this all
these details magic empty it's magic
that is magic that is magic so that's
it's it's not supposed to be believed
yeah so the harry potter comparison is
really interesting uh because you're
right empty and like deathly hollows we
see hermione she obliviates her parents
memories her image like is removed from
pictures but that was just like her
parents right she only did it to them
and in theory it was only temporary i
mean if she dies she dies you know
that's how it is but she dies she dies
she does but in theory like she she's
going to come back after you know they
take care of voldemort and be like
unboliviated and i'm your daughter again
but this seems like a pretty permanent
spell and it reaches beyond our the the
walls of our universe right it reaches
right across the multiverse so yeah i
guess everyone's just like a little bit
lobotomized which is kind of weird i
wonder how that like works on like a a
biological level very if you're very
interested in trying to see like the mcu
science behind it because like it's
crazy it's a huge spell and you bring up
like government rec or like everyone who
knew peter parker forgets peter parker
but that doesn't mean like a government
employee would forget get peter parker
right because he's still gotta have like
a driver's license
and like a social security
number and like medical records right
so and it's mainly tied to him being
spider-man which in theory a lot of
people in the world knew once the news
got out from the daily bugle but like
they all just forget that so like i
wonder if peter park i mean i wonder if
um spider-man is still considered a
villain here i mean because like we see
in like morbius trailers uh there is
that picture of spider-man with the idea
like oh villain and all that stuff and
it is toby mcguire spider-man which is
still kind of weird yeah but i just i'm
wondering if peter parker moving forward
is going to have to deal with still the
consequences of mysterio but only
spider-man and not his peter parker um
personality yeah that's that's a good
that's a good point like i think the
world will still remember mysterio we'll
remember that mysterio died and will
remember that peter parker played a role
in that uh spider-man or spider-man
you're right spider-man sorry i forgot
peter parker yeah um
but yeah it's like if there's gotta be
you know like nick fury probably had
some like records somewhere
maybe digital maybe he's only hard copy
because he doesn't trust computers
because you know zola is running around
in every computer in the world
but
do those files like get changed like
does nobody know
you know what i mean like and like what
about edith like the the whole ai like
karen both know peter parker would they
forget because they're not technically
people so like does the spell affect
them i don't know it's so if the spell
does affect data that is one powerful
spell that can go like all over like
every uh aspect of reality i guess the
question is is like magic stronger than
science and technology is like the real
question right uh and there's got to be
like a weakness to it there's got to be
limits to it right because this is a
spell that can be done i imagine it can
be undone either wholly or like
piecemeal right well yeah i think that
like eventually uh peter and ned and um
mj will eventually get all of their
memories back somehow i think they're
gonna pull an interstellar and it'll be
like the power of love is what drives
the universe right i honestly feel like
this is why mj keeps the black dahlia
necklace around she's like oh yeah her
instincts are like there's something
here yeah like she loves a good mystery
she loves following a good lead so like
if she sees this necklace she's like i
don't know where this came from i cannot
remember where i got it i think this is
really cool that i can't remember it so
i'm just gonna keep it here until i do
remember it and so it's like sort of
keeping like the the half part of her
heart
with her because she's like she sort of
knows that she's missing peter like it's
the sort i love that symbolism there
yeah because it just it's literally like
a half of a heart almost well and she
loves broken things too right uh yeah
she keeps the broken necklace because
she loves broken things and there's
nothing more broken in new york right
now than uh our boy peter parker so uh
yes and he's very broke too yeah very
broken and broken which is nice i mean
it's kind of fascinating right mt like
this was a
uh a trilogy
origin story in a way
where spider-man
we had skipped his like or what we
consider an origin story but this was
like a big reset for him and man seeing
the sewing machine and the homemade suit
uh like i love that he was inspired by
his spr spidey bros from across the
multiverse to be like no i'm going back
to the red and blue baby let's do it uh
it was it was great but i think one
interesting thing we did get to see
right is peter at uh omni's grave which
how dare they how could they do that to
us jesus uh and happy's there and happy
and they both know you know he brings up
i knew her through spider-man and so and
happiness like me too so happy obviously
has a memory of spider-man so i we can
extrapolate that to the rest of the
avengers right uh including doctor
strange who's gonna forget peter
um right which when he did say the
people who love you and he said it in a
wee
you know very very sweet very sweet uh
they know that they fought with
spider-man but maybe all the times they
saw him you know unmasked in their
memory now he's just wearing a mask i
think that's probably how yeah i think
that's exactly the implication there
it's like everyone still remembers
spider-man but like they just forget the
face of peter parker and they forget
that they know his identity yeah um
which is of course what happened in the
comics with uh one more day and all that
stuff right yeah now here's a question
for you mt what about like
ghost okay if if the spirits of because
we've established in shanghai that
people have spirits right and they go
somewhere right your spirit goes
somewhere when you die or a squid takes
it out of your body and you you live
forever in a hellish uh purgatory that
you can never escape um if the ghosts of
tony stark were to come back or the
ghosts of aunt may were to come back
would they know
peter parker ooh
i would say yes right that's a really
good question because like if they were
to come back then they weren't alive to
be affected by the spell right
for all their memories yeah no that
makes no i think that tony stark or not
may would be like oh yeah hey peter why
doesn't everyone remember this is weird
yeah yeah why is everyone being so weird
also i'm a ghost um
like what did you do everyone hates you
don't want to talk to you dude and
because this spell like closed up the
multiverse i assume it affected everyone
off world right like um
you know tony or um nick fury's probably
doesn't
we assume his mind got wiped uh carol
danvers like her mind gets wiped of
peter parker
that's actually another really good
point cause like
how much does this spell affect the
universe i think it only affects it on a
global scale you think because i could
tell because but the spell on did people
from other
multiverses wanting to get into ours
right
right this is true this is true so i
wonder oh man that's real yeah it had to
be on a universal scale then on a
multi-virtual scale yeah because it's
people from other universes are affected
yeah wow that is a strong spell
it also makes me wonder like man it's
really easy to break the multiverse if
you just right just a damaged spell that
you sent out no granted doctor strange
is a very powerful sorcerer he's not the
sorcerer yeah but he is a very powerful
sorcerer um but yeah it seems like very
easy to break the the multiverse is a
very fragile thing that we have to be
very delicate with just don't just turn
the microwave and the toaster at the
same time while uh you know just dealing
with the multiverse because you might
break it well so also mt does this mean
that the best-selling novel flashpoint
no longer exists did that do all the
books just to be broken
i got uh several autographs on the cover
i asked him to autograph it five times
on the cover when i bought it so i would
be very upset if that is now valued at
zero dollars and zero cents because of
magic shenanigans or do you think that
it's like flashpoint since it was a lie
to start with right the book was a lie
it was not truthful if every like
mention of peter parker in the book just
gets changed to spider-man and
flashpoint is this like sad novel about
a guy pretending that he's friends with
spider-man and he doesn't even know his
real name
and he's just like when i was hanging
out with spider-man we had a great time
he just uploaded all that fan fiction
yeah it's just a fan fiction now right
i would love because that's what exactly
what he would do he's obsessed with
spiderman he's like no no i'm still
friends with spiderman they're like you
don't even know who he is he's like it
doesn't matter we're not like that i'm
still frozen spiderman in my self-insert
fanfic okay
you can read it right now
but no that's such a good point oh man i
really want to see like i hope a future
mcu movie just goes into like the the
the effects of the spell like how like
if that picture of peter parker and tony
stark what happens to that like is that
just a dude that he just met she's like
oh it's some kid i met at an internship
but we were just really good friends
that's kind of sketchy tony well yeah i
guess theory a photo of peter parker and
tony stark could still exist right that
wouldn't have to get wiped because like
tony starks didn't
yeah spoiler alert so like the fact that
these two people talk to each other at
one point and tony stark being an
internationally known figure it would be
okay for that photo to exist there's
probably hundreds of thousands of photos
of tony stark with random people don't
throw up gang signs just kidding
[Laughter]
so like maybe that photo doesn't get
wiped i don't know again every mc you
film should come with a three hour
discussion afterwards where you get to
ask questions
and get an explainer for everything but
that's what we're here for to figure it
all out for them but hey moving on to
our next question we gotta ask
what the flip is what i'm saying what
the whip is next for peter um in his
next spider-man film that you know amy
pascal said that he's going to have are
we going to see a peter versus venom
scenario like they teased in the
post-credits scene i think so i mean it
seems like that's that's what they'd
love to set up um i'm worried for my boy
danny rojas is he gonna die we need him
to go back uh wait who's that again
sorry the guy who's a bartender uh
yeah he was uh
he's on ted laszlo ted lasso oh yeah
yeah so he plays danny rojas on uh ted
last time um but yeah i'm worried i'm
worried about my boy danny rojas is he i
assume he's going to get infected with
that little bit of goo because he can't
oh my god he can't be off of people for
too long so he'll be the first victim
and he'll probably die i mean would love
to see him stay uh in the mcu but
do you think this this like symbiote egg
that's left behind again uh venom really
having a lot of kids this year um
seriously do you think it's gonna find
do you think it's gonna find the eddie
brock
of this universe or go to flash maybe
i would absolutely love if it went to
flash i've been wanting this this mcu
flash to have an experience with venom
because i think that the venom symbiote
that we're getting in the venom series
uh the personality would work very well
with flash because they're just two
people that want to be heroes like
really badly um and so yeah
flash would love having venom and so i
would love to see that team up honestly
but no peter versus venom seems to be
very much in the cards it's what
everybody wants um it's what you know
people wanted from the venom films so
like it just makes sense for this new
adult peter who is supposedly going to
college he's starting his new adult life
do you just do you sort of uh pull a
spider-man 3 almost well not in in a
good way um and just uh you know
struggle with the anger um that he'll
probably right dealing with you know
post all this memory wiping um he's got
to have a lot of anger in there so i
think that him dealing with the symbiote
suit and like you know in his anger is
just a very good next step for the
character but what do you think what's
next for peter for you yeah i think you
know venom is definitely seeing venom in
this universe will be interesting um
especially you know if sony's gonna
continue to make the like the venomverse
movie separate having two venoms going
at the same time might be really
interesting can they talk to each other
through their symbiote mind meld across
the multiverse um that that would be
interesting to know especially if like
you know if this if the venom symbiote
in the mcu you know gets to see
spider-man and learn a little web action
gonna transfer that to our eddie brock
uh in the venomverse and he starts
shooting webs off so that would be crazy
um i also think it makes sense with you
know we know we're getting gore the god
butcher and thor love and thunder uh
that could lead to the necro sword which
comes from
the original symbiote so
you know i i it seems like they're
they're tie they're gonna tie all this
in together uh and it's gonna be the
long the long play for them but yeah i
think we're gonna get some venom the
ferocious five i guess not the sinister
six
but i i do love that venom
did spend this whole movie just drinking
literally got drunk admitted he was
drunk and that's an important thing to
know your limits to know when you're
drunk and you'd be like okay we're gonna
we're gonna find a way to get to new
york eddie eddie we're gonna get to new
york and then like i'm out of here bye
i really did love like obviously it was
a little bit annoying that venom wasn't
actively in this movie after being
teased in uh venom too however i do love
the fact that eddie brock was just like
this isn't my fight i'm not gonna go
go after this dude i'm a good person
yeah i'm just going to get drunk and
learn about this universe that i made
because i have no idea but when you
brought up the the whole null aspect and
like and all that it sort of made me
think is there a possibility or is there
a space where peter parker with the
black suit joins the midnight suns
because the symbiote is like sort of you
know kind of magical it has magical like
like links right and like maybe you
could like to the to the necro sword or
the necklace one has a link to the ebony
blade which is what which is basically
why i'm bringing this up yeah and so if
the ebony blade has like sort of
symbiote type of roots
i think that uh dark suit spider-man
would work very well on a midnight sun's
team with blade black knight all those
people that they're probably setting up
so yeah if you're not thinking about
that marvel and sonya
[Laughter]
magnificent ideas that he's given away
for free folks
3.99 for our next question let's talk
about toby and andrew because they are
the biggest parts and the most amazing
parts of this film because uh and like
it's been a while since we saw them so
what the whip did andrew garfield
spiderman do to get so dark like he said
he hinted at like a dark past post um
the amazing spider-man 2. so like how
dark did he get and like what was toby
maguire even up to during his time
away from us yeah those are their he
those are very like interesting
questions uh you know it seemed i bet
andrew garfield got pretty dark those
movies are are hard on him and he sees a
lot of death up close and personal uh
that can maybe be blamed on him uh but
i i bet he got pretty dark you know that
was the kind of question i had like is
this real time for them like has it has
it been like almost 20 years for toby
where he's been swinging around kept
doing things when they were listing off
the villains they fought it was fun it
was great i would have loved to have
heard ones we didn't see you know what i
mean
waiting for that song this guy hunted me
and he loves hunting everything and it's
like
but it was still fun i mean everything
they did was great i i really loved it
you know the little stroll down memory
lane we had with them i bet garfield got
pretty dark especially if you know they
continued the storylines they were
setting up in that movie or in that
franchise where there was gonna be a
vulture there was gonna be right you
know like a gak they were building all
this like equipment for these other
things he's experienced so much death uh
at the hands of his villains but he
doled out some death to his villains and
absolutely the message that the
spidermans were bringing to uh our baby
peter one was basically like you can get
your revenge but it it's not gonna fix
anything and you're just gonna feel
worse oh yeah and you're gonna you know
it's like opening pandora's box you
can't undo it you know yes the wisdom of
experience and like being spider-man for
so long it teaches you that you're gonna
experience a lot of really terrible
things in andrew garfield's case he lost
gwen and i'm pretty sure that harry
gosbord got the sh the crap beat out of
him yeah um in the future oh yeah
because like my god in in both universes
definitely dead
in both for sure oh yeah for sure like
yeah that dude got beat up and like it's
just i i really love how they explore
this darker nature of garfield's
character yeah because it's just it's
it's a rational um and logical
progression for that character for him
to have a dark phase uh literally with
you know obviously we know with the
venom suit but like having a dark phase
without the venom suit is um just uh
actually what if adrian garfield did
have the venom suit what if that was
what he was teasing that'd be crazy
that would be nothing
it actually makes a lot of sense yeah
yeah okay he didn't realize it was an
alien like he didn't he didn't really
know he just came across the suit like
maybe he had his own venom saga and just
like didn't bring it up he was like yeah
i had venom suit blah blah blah and then
i could happen i got dark and then i
dealt with it he bought an all-black
suit he went out dancing at a jazz
you know he really got dark he got dark
uh it really reminded me too of uh you
know into the spider verse uh and kind
of right that the message there that all
the spider-man's brought to miles that
was just if you choose this life you
know you have to do it all the way and
there's gonna be sadness and there's
gonna be tragedy and there's gonna be
darkness uh and you have to push through
it you have to be the hero you know it
was the same message that
you know cap was trying to tell the tony
and a lot of ways tony was trying to
tell to peter like you know tony was
always trying to protect peter to keep
him out of things uh but you know peter
wouldn't stop and you know kept
following kept inserting himself into
situations uh and it worked out in the
end
he was flipped away for five years and
stuff and that's what tony was trying to
prevent but hearing it from other
spider-men
uh
really brought it home for him and
that's what you know leads him to make
that decision and then in the end to be
like no i'll be okay on my own i need to
do this on my own
um without putting anyone else i love in
danger which is it's always the tough
decision spider-man has to make at the
end of the day it's it's literally the
whole responsibility organs it's why we
love spider-man and why we have always
loved spider-man for so long it's
because he's just constantly just
dealing with shitty luck and like but
dealing it with dealing with it in an
extremely admirable and responsible way
that is what is super about peter parker
so i really love how this movie ended do
you think do you think uh garfield
spider-man
going back to his universe he's gonna be
like i'm gonna look up every
mary jane watson i could find in the
phone book because one of them's gotta
be for me this seems to be it this seems
to me where we're supposed to every
derivation
derivation of like mj i can find uh in
new york city i'm gonna try them all
baby
this one's a lot more durable than the
gwen's yeah yeah
oh god
do you think toby was like i did it to
gwen stacy too but she's fine
she's totally fine i saved her she's
fine
she fell and i caught her i don't know
what's wrong with you i don't know
certainly
in the wrong position on her body when
falling at a high speed it's like she's
walking on two legs spine fine perfectly
fine
all right but moving on we gotta ask
this next question what the whip is next
for mj and ned because we saw ned doing
some weird uh doctor strange stuff
during this movie so could we see ned
training in comtaj eventually maybe i
mean you know they're they're going to
massachusetts they're going to your your
home state mt's
i did love when which is just like cover
taj yeah yeah just like comics but with
charlie baker
i did like when when uh you know
uh peter one was like oh just i'll move
to boston too and i'll i'll i'll do my
spider-man thing at points i was so
excited i was like yes come here the
idea that you just franchise out your
spider-man business
like all the villains in new york are
just gonna be like well i guess i gotta
move to boston now
there's no one here spiderman fights the
green monster
i'm dr duncan ah
dr duncan oh my these are all we need a
boston thebes spider-man villains loose
i need the sinister six from boston
the wicked sick the wicked six
to answer your question though i i do
think i do think ned
you know this this spell undoes everyone
knowing peter parker but it doesn't undo
you know uh
doctor strange meeting mj and ned and
seeing ned do a little magic um
and uh
i think he might my pop i now the real
question is empty when is ned gonna kill
spider-man now that he has no idea who
he is
and he taps into his mouth that's so
true yeah cause yeah cause like they
they do tell them um in earlier in the
movie that yeah spider-man's best
friends yeah tries to kill him yeah and
so that's just like oh no i would never
kill you but now that he doesn't
remember peter what if they meet again
yeah and then he just and he's using his
mouth what if what if mordo gets the ned
first and is like listen i said no more
wizards but you can stay but you work
for me now
could ned become the magical version of
the hobgoblin uh
magical goblin
i would love that that would be oh my
that's a i think you just did something
brandon i think you just did something
but you know what be also bananas
mj teaming up with jessica jones
for so long because mj's such a good
investigator and her and jessica jones
have very similar personalities so if
jessica jones is coming to the mcu come
on let's say
jessica jones team up what if she turns
to a life of crime and becomes the black
cat
it starts
but i i do think mj like babe ruth you
know she called her shot she's like i'm
gonna figure this out again so don't
even worry do the spell i don't care
i'll figure out who you are i mean my
thing was like why didn't peter just
keep standing there when the spell got
done
with
okay i know you guys are freaking out
right this second but hello my name is
peter parker
you guys used to do my best friends
like i don't even know why peter
parker's tripping for you literally know
everything about these people yeah all
you had to do was just sit there talk to
them for like make friends with them
again
you're you're 100 fine but i think i
think the message of like seeing mj with
the band-aid and being like yes i do
cause this pain i put them in danger and
they'll never stop putting themselves in
danger for me because they love me
because they love so well we got three
movies to figure it out empty
they'll meet again they'll meet again
that'd be so great yeah he finally says
the i love yous even though they just
started dating it's kind of weird but
hey
kids kids they do it life comes at you
fast when the blip happens buddy right
you never know when you're gonna die so
you might as well say i love you now and
our final question of the day is is
there a norman osborn in the mcu like
why is there no oz corp in the main mcu
universe yeah that was kind of
fascinating seeing norman be like
there's no oz corp here i'm so sad
someone else did my home yeah like did
like the norman osborne and like the the
mcu did he he not pursue a life of
scientist of science and just like he
you know he invented some like made on t
i seen on tv product and like made a
billion dollars and it's just like
sitting on an island somewhere kicking
back relaxing
not having kids being like this is a
great life i'm loving it i would like to
think he's like on shark tank like yeah
no investors i'm somewhat of a genius
myself
i'm somewhat of an inventor myself
it was an interesting line because it
kind of just wiped away oscorp from the
mcu so
you know it's kind of sad that maybe
we're never going to see it in the mcu i
don't know or or if they want to do
roxon which they already kind of have
established or if they're going to
develop aim again you know there's a lot
of corporations in marvel comics so
maybe they're like we don't need oscorp
in this universe we'll get rid of it um
but it's kind of interesting because i
do remember in you know the falcon
winter soldier when we saw those weapons
uh that got used in the final episode
some of them kind of looked like oscorp
technology we were kind of theorizing at
the time that's what they could be but
looks like that's a no or maybe oscorp's
just like not in the phone book and
they're it's very secretive i like the
idea of a norman that is like just up
and coming like he's slowly building up
oscorp so like with the homecoming
trilogy it was essentially the origin
story for spider-man because we didn't
get that right with great power line
until this very movie so what if the
next trilogy is the origin story for the
goblin and so like peter knows how
terrible norman osborne is because
because of the death of his mom of his
aunt who's basically his mom yeah and so
watching this new osborne rise to power
will make him so angry and cause him to
distrust this new man so much
that um in this other house
why are you so mad at me i'm trying to
be good blah blah blah and like i think
that's a good route to take because like
peter immediately distrusting this man
yeah that would be really cool if
instead of like harry osborne being
peter's contemporary it's norman osborne
and they're like almost the same age
peter's like i gotta i gotta stop this
guy and everyone's like what is your
problem just chill out dude right it's
like i didn't kill your aunt so my other
guy did and he's like just kidding i'm
evil too
i wish you had another on for me to kill
[Laughter]
that is it for this special episode of
inside marvel and do not forget to check
out our many great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at
mastertainment follow brandon at grin
and barrack follow new rockstars on all
social media platforms subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast and again thank you guys so much
for watching we love you guys
tremendously whipped whip we'll see you
guys later goodbye
bye never forget me
you